[MUSIC]
The promise of AI has always
been to make lives better and
do things that were doing now on our
own in a much more efficient and
much more powerful way.
But to do that, AI needs to learn
and to learn, it needs information.
And one of the best sources of
information we have on the world,
and how it works is hidden in
the video cameras all around us.
A phenomenal amount of video
is generated every year.
And it's not just the hundreds of
millions of cameras all around us,
it's the billions of cell phones
that we all keep in our pockets.
Prism is a cloud software company
that connects to cameras that
are existing in the marketplace,
and analyzes that video
in a way no human can.
it slices and dices the video and
puts that into our
data structures so it's searchable
and available to customers.
Microsoft is a big part of the
smarts that help the indexing and
understanding of video happen.
To use Prism, all you have to do is
pull out your phone, and type in
what it is you're looking for
and where and Prism will find it.
The value comes from unlocking
the hidden information in video and
that can be just as valuable for
a factory or
construction site or
hospital as it is for retail store.
Prism also takes that video feed and
turns it into a stream of
information that can be used to
let that business run better.
Microsoft's computer vision
API can understand different
kinds of objects, texts,
other types of information.
Merchandisers might use us to look
into their stores around the world
or people in retail operations might
use us to build a dashboard of
important metrics.
Places like hospitals or healthcare
facilities can use Prism to
understand where their doctors are,
so
they can more quickly connect
those doctors with patients.
In verticals like industrial or
construction,
Prism can be used to help track
really important critical machinery.
If you're on a construction site,
and you wanted to be notified when
the cement mixer arrived,
you can use AI to do that.
Prism brings a really unique set of
content into the world of AI and
machine learning and
Microsoft brings some of the best
technology and people in the world
to help understand that content.
It's an exciting time and
the coolest thing about it is
we're just getting started.